all right
oh okay
all right now is our chance I guess to
move on then
um so before I start I'd like to just uh
say something about representative hatch
I think some of you may be aware that he
did resign on Monday
it will be a great loss to the house
I've known Bill since 2006 which is the
first year he came to the house he
served on ways and means
I was vice chair over there then he came
over to finance
I've been involved with a number of
committee at conferences he was a vice
chair of this division for a term
as you know Bill suffered from a injury
from Vietnam
that they could never really get a
handle on and as a result he finally
lost that leg about a month ago
so um
he's going to remain I guess he's moved
down to Bedford
and so he can be closer to rehab and
hospital care that he needs to survive
so
I just wanted to
thank bill for his service and we were
seat mates in the house he always
insisted for the last couple of years I
sit next to him
so I'm gonna miss his uh
constant advice you've represented the
North Country better than anybody that I
knew from the North country and being
from Gorham it took him about two and a
half hours to get here and being on such
a busy committee it just showed his
dedication so
thank you Bill
not sure
yeah thank you Mr chairman I really want
to Second your remarks
um I really have a lot of respect for
people from coax County who come here
day after day I mean it's it's I live
right next door practically by by
comparison and um
but the the loss of Representative hatch
means that we get to welcome we think
representative grassy to become a
permanent replacement so
thank you for coming okay
all right so um just very quickly you'll
see how we get this set up the first
group of bills appeared in the budget
we can either continue to hold on to
these bills or we can move them off our
plate by just a recommendation of itl
and we will start at House built
212. does anybody think that we should
retain that or representative evil did
you have anything on that no
so if there's no objection would someone
like to move itl and
it's been seconded by representative
sweetie or I have to get my clerking
charts
so and again as everybody knows we'll
just be making a recommendation to the
committee chaired by representative
Weiler and whenever he sets up that
executive session so once the clerk is
ready call yes representative just to
comment on that uh met with division two
some of these bills that this supposed
study committee that's going to be
required to report by November 1st
so
we heard from the LBA that we have till
November 17th so between November 1st
and November 17th after we hear the
final on these 436 is another one that
applies to then we will make a decision
we may retain like 436
if the study committee comes out with
something that we could just amend 436
and and keep it alive and bring it
forward so you raise a good point Mr
chairman we have heard from
representative Carol McGuire that asked
us to hold on to 436 should the
commission come out with a
recommendation
so that's the reason why we won't have
an exact session until November if
anybody wants to make plans
represent of evil
getting ready oh okay
are you ready yeah
okay the motion was itl on House Bill
212.
um representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin representative
Sweeney yes representative cambrells yes
clerks votes I representative uh grassy
yes in here just to throw me off okay
and then um chairman yes
seven seven zero six votes unique
chairman see these names aren't on here
and so it's messing me up
Mr the other Mr chair also votes yes
okay eight zero unanimous Ito
all right moving to house bill
2 30. again that was included in the
budget the data processing system for
the Department of Agriculture because I
would I would move itl
and it's seconded by representative
Griffin
all right
okay uh the the motion is itl on House
Bill 230.
um representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrell's yes
clerk votes I representative grassy yes
representative Weiler yeah the chairman
yes okay
zero unanimous Ito
all right house bill 276.
cyanobacteria that was included has been
a lot of discussions I guess some of our
Lakes have seen a real problem with this
this year but
any thoughts on that again it was
included in the budget maybe not
everything that was requested but the
concept and some funding was
representative McGuire I guess it's my
turn I'll move itl
um I believe this is in the budget but
at a lesser amount than the original
bill
so
moved in second and when the clerk is
ready please call the roll
okay representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
I representative Grant grassy yes
representative Weiler yes the chairman
yes okay eight zero unanimous Ito
we'll move to House Bill 300
disposal certain food waste
representative
I will make the motion to itl
a representative
clerk is ready please call
um
okay representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes clerk votes
I representative grassy yes
representative Weiler yes
yes
zero unanimous
all right moving on to House Bill 311
often known as Buco box was included in
the budget
someone like to move on this one
representative grassy
represent grassy moves Sweeney seconds
foreign
representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbell's yes
representative
um grassy yes representative Weiler yes
Clark votes I chairman yes
8-0 unanimous
thank you we moved to 347
establishing the uh additional judgeship
and we heard testimony on this was
passed and put in the budget
so again no need of carrying this one
along is there a motion I'll move Ito
representative Ebel moves itl represent
cambrell's seconds
and when you're ready okay
suicide of McGuire yes representative
Griffin yes representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrells yes
clerk votes I representative grassy yes
chair Weiler yes in the other chair yes
okay eight zero unanimous itl on House
Bill 347.
a
House Bill
462 food waste reduction and diversion
representative evil I'd like to comment
on your bill
um
did cut it in half it's uh 1 million
instead of 2 million but I remain very
grateful for the support of this finance
committee for the full amount and I'm
glad that it was included and I'll make
the motion to itl
second the second representative McGuire
and again when you're ready okay
and here I thought it was
okay
all right representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambros yes
Clark votes I representative grassy yes
chair Weiler yes and chair leishman yes
okay eight zero
Ito
so we do have 15 minutes until 10
o'clock and does the professor have
anything you'd like to say
all right now being 10 A.M
we have House Bill 571 I know
representative McGuire has a couple of
thoughts on this one
yes thank you so what happened to this
this if you recall was the bill to give
a cost of living adjustment to group two
members
um certain ones not not everyone who
were who were retired for a certain
period of time and we put it into the
budget and I think it was part of the
whole compromise thing that we did with
436 and
um other parts and
um the Senate changed it
to a bill that was for all retirees not
just group one but you know group twos
as well and
um very few of them so it it I think
ours bill was if you were retired 10
years or more then and and your and your
pension was under a certain amount but I
think they changed it to maybe 20 years
or more retired and pension even less
and and our bill
um our version I think that this stipend
was somewhere between
three thousand and one thousand
something like that whereas theirs was a
flat 500. so
um so it was quite fairly different
um now we could just you know like we
did for these other bills just say itl
that's good enough right or we could
um put back our version into the bill
send it on to the Senate and let them
deal with it a second time you know
individually it's I'm not
um you know I don't have any big
preference one way or the other
further comments
representing grassy
I would support putting our version back
in and you know passing this bill with
the version that we sent over and let
the Senate deal with it again
all right
representative Griffin
I don't know it seems to me like this I
don't just kill it again
they killed it the first time so yeah
representative camberos okay everybody
be quiet yeah so one thing that my
reading of the final
um
Surplus statement was that essentially
there's no money left
right in the checking account that that
they left all the extra money in the
education trust fund crazy kind of a
crazy thing but so if we were to put
this bill in we'd have to
the question is where are we getting the
9 million or whatever it would cost so
I put in a bill to have all that Surplus
education trust fund lapse to the
general fund but that won't pass till
middle of next year
if it does
forever further comments or questions
represent kimberles yeah I mean I would
have preferred for this to pass but I
think at this point
um the Senate we did spend a lot of
money on the budget and they did get
something out of it so I would recommend
to itl
it's been moved itl by representing
kimbrells as its second representative
Griffin
any further
comments questions
seeing none when the clerk is ready
please call the roll
the motion is to itl it
representative camera and Griffin
representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrells yes
clerk votes I representative grassy no
representative Weiler yes
representative bleachman yes
okay so uh seven to one Ito
all right we'll move to uh Senate Bill
came into legal services for
involuntarily admitted
Mental Health Services representative
um let me just uh pass this along to
representative grassy if he wants to
write a minority ought to pass with
amendment that would be the amendment
that he wants so it's all ready to go
so any thoughts and Senate Bill yes
represents Sweeney thank you Mr chairman
my recollection and it could be wrong
was our committee had retained this
under the
not position or opinion but under the
likelihood that since it was a Senate
bill they would likely include it in
their version of the budget they did not
do that so I would I'd move itl on this
since they did not see fit to included
in the budget
all right representative Sweeney
has moved itl on Senate Bill 128 and
it's seconded by representative
Kimbrell's
when the clerk is ready please call the
roll
um all right uh representative McGuire
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrells yes
clerk votes nay representative grassy
yes
representative Weiler
yes okay
okay itl71
all right
and I won't do online
Senate bill 267.
cumulative impacts analysis
for the Department of Environmental
Services and we had a lot of discussion
on this
the time thoughts
seeing none of someone like them oh no
no I have thoughts okay I just
representative evil has thoughts so many
papers flying here you know when we move
so quickly
um so we retain this bill for uh for
further discussion
um and I think the concern that was
expressed at the original hearing was
the sorts of facilities that this was
going to um be affecting and I did look
around a little bit I looked at the
definition of facilities that we have in
our statute the only place that I really
saw anything was um in our Solid Waste
statutes and it was specifically for a
solid waste disposal site and then there
was another statute on um on hazardous
waste I think it's really difficult and
perhaps on this and and I think
unnecessary to Define facility it's at
this point because the person that Des
would hire pursuant to this bill one of
the things that they would be looking at
was the sorts of facilities that um this
would apply to
um so I would propose not concerning
ourselves at this point about defining
facilities and in fact if if we did we
might limit it in a way that
is not helpful for the future
um you know I I did look a little more
into the cumulative impacts analysis I
think it's pretty self-evident what it
is it's um
the the idea being that when you're
licensing something
that is in the area of another polluting
um entity you should be taking
everything into consideration
um or whatever this person recommends
and not be permitting like air pollution
or water pollution
um in a in a vacuum which I think is
something that's worth looking at
and the only other thing I would add
here and Mr Hoffman can uh clarify if
I'm wrong but I think this you know this
is a a finance committee issue the
policy committee recommended unanimously
that this be passed I think it passed
the house
307-77 or something like that it was an
overwhelming vote it passed
um very strongly out of the house the
amen I mean the Senate the amendment
here was supported and introduced by
Senator abard who's the chair of the
Senate and I think in our role as the
finance committee we should be looking
at
the numbers
um and I think this is a worthwhile
Endeavor so I would support
ought to pass
represent McGuire I remember you had a
lot comment on this yeah and I you know
I was opposed to this all along and
still am
um
basically I mean this is hiring a new
person uh to to Des and giving them
a very vague Charter in my in my opinion
it this
um is asking them to regulate
essentially so first of all this is not
a statute law this is chapter law right
so this is just sort of giving them a
direction and saying you know head in
this direction and you you know affect
your rules and it even says statutes in
in a certain way but it's not limited to
um the water section or the air section
or the way you know the solid waste
section and so on it's it's for
everything Des does and there and it's
asking to regulate people not based on
what they do but based on what other
people in their quote geographical area
do and it and it doesn't say is the
geographical area the town the county
the state who knows right so I think
it's giving this new employee
just a lot of you know sort of a vague
Direction and they can get into
regulating
[Music]
um business and development in a way
that's that's going to be you know
potentially very expensive
um so I'm I'm opposed to
representative Weiler
I was always
kind of vague about cumulative impact
analysis it could be anything anybody
decides it and you might have the thing
all decided and someone say what about
it's something you never heard of before
how do you think that has I'm pretty
sure it does and it's some of this is so
subjective of what do you think
cumulative impact is I don't think
that's
I do you know I could sit there and
argue about it all day
so
who knows representative Griffin yeah I
too have real concerns about the open
endless open-endedness of this uh
this bill
and I think it's another case of the
legislative
legislature uh giving away
their Authority on laws and letting GES
write the laws
so I'm going to vote no one
representative grassy yes
um Mr chairman I think when people look
at cumulative impacts on a project one
of the things that you're not
considering is that you know you may
have a business in your community which
discharges into your sewer system or
discharges may have runoff that is not
significant in its impact
and then Upstream another company
decides they want to locate and they're
going to have the same kind of impact on
the water and if you look at it by
itself
you say okay it's not a significant
impact but when you include it with
what's already in the Watershed of that
area now you've got a significant impact
and the thing is is that when we look at
projects when a planting board looks at
a project they look or when Des looks at
a project they look at a project
isolated
and not considering other environmental
factors that are involved surrounding it
we look at just what's on the site it's
something used to frustrate me as a town
planner when we look at runoff we would
look at what's the runoff on this site
and you know you could meet the
standards and particularly when you're
looking at and let's use the example of
runoff you want the law says you can't
increase the amount of runoff that goes
off the site at a particular time so we
do is we extend the time of the runoff
so it doesn't increase the volume it
extends it if you put three projects
into that same area that are all
extending that water you all of a sudden
now have flood situations Downstream
which which are much longer a period of
time so we need to take a look at the
cumulative impact
of you know when one project goes in it
may be fine when the second project it
may be fine when the third pro project
goes in it may break the camel's back as
far as the environment is concerned and
this is the reason why we need to do
this
Des needs to take a look at this these
projects not just one at a time ingest
you know just that project but you need
to take a look at everything else that's
going on around it as well and I think
that this is important to do whether it
be an air quality whether it be in in
drainage uh and and water quality I
think this is something that will make a
difference I think the policy committee
decided that
and they agreed with that and as someone
who has worked in the field
I think it's important that we have this
consideration at DES and so I would
support ought to pass and recommend
ought to pass
I do have a quick question that maybe
one of you will be able to answer it
since it was a Senate Bill do we know
why the Senate didn't include it in
their part of the budget
all right represent people
it's really important to clarify here
that all this Bill does is it authorizes
the department to hire somebody to
review the statutes nothing and
regulations absolutely nothing is going
to change until there's a report given
and
um the person who's doing the reporting
from Des presents their findings
discusses potential legislation and
potential rule making Authority I mean
the appropriation here is about it's for
two years for the salary for about it
looks like 210 000 dollars so there's
absolutely nothing here that requires
or authorizes even the department to do
anything except to look at the at the
rules and the statutes that are in
existence and given the strength of the
policy recommendation coming out of the
house and the fact that the Senate
um I mean I don't have the vote on it Mr
Hoffman but I think
I thought it was unanimous but I don't
want to I don't want to overstate the
case I just think for two hundred
thousand dollars it's worth authorizing
them to look over their rules and
regulations Mr Hoffman that was a Voice
vote in the Senate
so we don't have a specific number
further questions or comments
Mr chairman yes represent people Mr
Irwin from the conservation law
Foundation is here I didn't know if he
wanted to say something how you if you
would authorize him to or I just wanted
to mention it
I've known as being pretty liberal
allowing people to speak especially from
the public so would you like to speak
and if so
take a chair and state your name for the
record please
thank you Mr chairman committee members
for the record my name is Tom Irwin I'm
with conservation law Foundation I
direct our New Hampshire office
um
yeah I I think the the the policy
purpose behind this bill has been well
stated and explained really well
um by representative yebo by
representative grassy I think the only
thing I would add is the significant
Public Health uh element uh and the the
public health importance of this
legislation
um
if we think of uh for example a
a facility that emits air pollution uh
with a permit from Des
but complies with that permit qualifies
for a permit
um if that facility is within
a close distance of another facility and
a community the additive cumulative
effects despite each individual permit
complying uh could be significant
and so I think it's it's really
important to engage in this analysis and
um
to representative Wyler's point it's
it's complicated as to how you Define
cumulative impact so I think it's really
something that would be a challenge any
state any legislature to do it's really
something that is in the purview and the
expertise of the department so
um you know for that reason I think
the bill makes sense in providing
resources to the department to engage in
that analysis and then as representative
Ebel said
to report
make recommendations But ultimately it
will be up to the legislature as to how
statutes how or whether statutes should
change
so I think um
that's all I have
to be happy to answer questions
represent Kimbrell's
thank you Mr chair
um I agree that
I would have thought that when and
during the permitting process cumulative
analysis would be done as a matter of
course is it not done already
it is not
every facility is looked at on its own
as to whether it and it alone satisfies
whatever standard is that issue for
purpose of permit issuance
and are you aware of uh any other
states that are doing that now
uh more and more States across the
country are looking at this issue
um I believe I believe
um
bit of impacts analysis
um state of New Jersey is those are just
a few that I'm aware of but this this is
being recognized as an important public
health issue yeah just a follow-up
that's sure and it seems to me as an I'm
a retired engineer it's a very
complicated process would that not
greatly slow down the permitting process
and slow down the uh the ability for the
economy and to you know expand
I don't think I could speak to how much
it would slow down the process I think
that speaks to the importance of Des
doing this analysis up front I think
we'll we'll know from that analysis how
complicated it is
um I think we'll you know
I think again defining what cumulative
impacts are and how they are assessed is
is really important and um is again I
think best suited because of its
complexity to the Department
um and I think they could certainly
speak to through that process how it
would affect the individual permitting
process
representative Weiler
since we're looking at this from a
financial standpoint
I would think Des is unable to do that
on their own go to rulemaking and and do
that rather than spending a couple
hundred thousand if someone
sit there for two years or a year going
over all the rules and and you know they
if if they really find this is something
that should have been included in a
review put it in rules go to go to jail
car see if they get an agreement on how
this would be done rather than have
someone spend two years or a year
shouldn't take that long to go through
and try to figure how this would apply
to each of these ones they're looking at
thank you
well there is a gentleman from Des
hiding in the background there that
maybe he'd be willing to speak to your
question or comment representative
Weiler are there any further questions
sir represent Maguire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming
um do you have any concrete examples
from New Hampshire like Dupont had a
plant in Concord and then uh Dow
Chemical built a plant in Manchester and
they screwed up the Merrimack Rivers so
Budweiser in Merrimack could no longer
bottle beer or you know something like
that is it no I I I don't and I also
think that the geographic scale you
defined is probably much broader than
what Des would come back with in terms
of how to Define cumulative impacts I I
suspect that
it probably would not say carve out the
entire Merrimack River Watershed uh
something at that scale they might might
look at a sub-watershed scale but no I
don't have
any examples of something like that I
think a lot of this is really about
being proactive and ensuring you know
for example
foreign
with Saint gobain's and Merrimack is not
the motivator behind this legislation
but I think pointing to that as an
example
um
if so Saint gobangs were continuing
operations there and another facility
came in and we're to set up shop and
could get a permit because standing on
its own uh
you know the air emissions are not of
concern but again if you come if you
were to combine those two facilities
that could be a significant
health issue for for the community so a
lot of this is about being proactive
follow-up representative McGuire
so
the way I think about this is
that over time when when an area grows
let's think about Los Angeles or
something right you know air pollution
got worse they're in a bowl and so the
over time air pollution got worse and
worse and and restrictions on on
exhaust emissions from Cars got more and
more astringent right and so
isn't it the case that when you permit
some some use
that person doesn't somehow take 50
percent of all the pollution that you
know you permit somebody to be able to
be
you know one percent of what would be
really harmful or half a percent of what
would be really harmful or something
like that so so things build up slowly
over time in the sense that here's a
half percent polluter and there's
another quarter percent polluter and
there's a you know and so there's a lot
of time to say wait a minute you know
our limit of so many parts per million
should be you know half or something you
see what I mean it's not like one new
guy is ever going to
really kick off a serious pollution
circumstance is am I right or am I wrong
I think under under
the best circumstances yes things happen
slowly over time but in a confined area
it could happen quickly if you get the
wrong facilities multiple facilities
again and this gets to Geographic scale
and I think that's something that the
department would look closely at how do
you define the geography for purposes of
of assessing cumulative impacts but
um at at a small enough scale
you could have two permitting decisions
that have two permitting decisions and
two facilities that have a real impact
on
a local community
representative grassy I believe it was a
question based on the discussion we just
had here wouldn't it this bill I mean if
we just let things do go on their
natural progression you wouldn't find
out that there was a problem until after
the new building new new project was
approved and built this bill would be
able to allow us to anticipate you know
if they change their rules and
regulations be able to anticipate
problems before they become problems
yes I would strongly agree with that
thank you
seeing no further questions for you
thank you very much your testimony was
helpful thank you Mr Mr chairman
and if you could state your name and for
the record police uh Craig Wright with
the Department of Environmental Services
um I serve as the air director I'll just
put that on the table I'm not a water
guy a waste guy but I am here to
represent the department as a whole
what we're talking about with cumulative
impacts it sounds very simplistic as to
what it is but it's actually very very
complicated it it depends
on the level and the depth at which you
go at evaluating cumulative impacts
it could be as simple as as we as some
people have mentioned two facilities
locating next door to each other and
they both individually need the combine
comply with the standards but do you add
those two together somewhere off site
so we do do some level of interactive
analysis on the air level
it's in very limited cases but it's
primarily for what we call criteria
pollutants
that's mainly things regulated under the
federal Clean Air Act so in those
limited cases we do look at what is the
combined impact of two facilities
located next to each other we even take
into consideration what's in the general
air quality of the state
that's called through a tool we call
Interactive modeling
where we don't do interactive analyzes
is on the air side is an air toxics we
have a standard and all we require is
the source demonstrate their individual
compliance it does not take into
consideration background or other
sources nearby so and that's just on the
air side and then you start to add in
well what about the impacts of what I'm
breathing with what I'm drinking with
what I'm absorbing through taking a
shower or something like that so it can
get very in-depth in very complicated
very fast
the department has not taken a position
on this bill the department will
recognize that this is an issue
that is being discussed very locally we
hear this issue a lot at public hearings
people raising this issue and how is the
department addressing it and generally
what we tell them is we don't have rules
that address what you're asking us to
look at it's being looked at at a
national level EPA is looking at it we
were I was at a recent meeting with the
EPA region one administrator and we
somebody from the audience asked how
does EPA Define cumulative impacts EPA
doesn't have a definition they're
looking at it too
this is a bill that would have the
department do a study look what's going
on around the country
um I know representative Wiley
questioned about whether we had the
resources to do this now we would
strongly say we do not have the
resources or the staff to do this
the department doesn't object to the
bill if you took the position out of the
bill I think the department would object
to it we just don't have the bandwidth
to do the level of analysis
um that's long-winded answer to a couple
different questions I could certainly
answer more
questions representative Sweeney thank
you Mr chairman thank you for being here
for taking our questions
so for the fiscal note of 247 thousand
dollars it's two years of salary
benefits and operating costs and
equipment for an environmentalist for LG
27 step four hired
couple of questions on this sure are
there any vacancies in a similar
position currently at the department uh
I know in the air division there's a
couple vacancies right now but we're
currently filling them for other
purposes okay so I would say at least in
the air Division I don't have somebody
this position even though it's going to
be looking over the entire working on
the department would be housed in the
air division because we have an
environmental health program and would
be a good fit there but no I do not have
a position that I could fill okay follow
up Mr chairman and I appreciate that
you're just the air division C yep not
necessarily the whole department which
this position is hired for
we hire somebody for two years for this
position year three is going to be in
the budget to continue this position in
a new study position or will we cut this
from the budget I guess I don't know
what I don't know but I would say it's
certainly a possibility that it would
exist beyond the two years time frame
because if you remember what this
position would do is it would create a
report
that would go to the legislature
potential changes to statutes and rules
and if there were recommendations in
there and something were to come out in
statute then the department would need
to talk about implementation of those
changes so I could see the work
continuing beyond the initial two years
thank you
representative Ebel followed by
representative Wilder
um thank you very much but just to
clarify what you just said if the
legislature
decide to pursue it it's not like you're
going to have a position there that will
be continuing would be terminated right
yeah unless we found a different funding
source and another uh responsibility for
that person to do correct
and then the other one more question
um is there a definition of facility in
the air
statutes that you're aware of we have
multiple definitions of facility
stationary Source we could certainly get
them if you wanted to see them I
actually what we're looking at is a
operation that occurs on a piece of
property
generally we look at
Asos is it an individual Source if it's
under common ownership and control
so if you had two buildings next to each
other that were under common ownership
and control then we would consider that
one source
um
could you tell us again as far as what's
going on at the at the national level I
mean I guess my thought is that if there
are lots of things happening at the
national level for us to kind of get
ahead of it is in a I mean to sort of
anticipate and do our own analysis of
our statutes isn't a bad thing
I mean that's always that's always the
question right
um
I would suspect it will take EPA
sometime to figure out how how they
Define cumulative impacts they talk
about it all the time in every grant
program they deal with
um but they haven't defined it
um It's Not Unusual I mean New Hampshire
has been a leader at some points in the
past but different environmental things
um it's just a question of whether we
think the timing is right now for New
Hampshire to do this
representative Weiler
well I've always heard that our air
quality is affected by what's happening
in New York and Ohio that is true and we
can't we can't have any control of what
they do in increases and we keep getting
complaints from Canada that we're
affecting their air quality in Eastern
Canada which I guess they're now getting
even with all the forest fires but
you know so the some of these things are
beyond our control
and yet they could they could be brought
to our effect and we could be
impoverishing the people of New
Hampshire because of what's happening
and another place in the in the North
America so you know it's it's hard to
take that all into effect New Hampshire
certainly is a downwind state
um New Hampshire has gone to battle with
upwind States many times in different
venues uh before EPA even some actions
in court
um dealing with pollution coming into
the state
is is a challenge
um EBA EPA has some responsibility there
to help manage those situations and
under the current Administration they've
been a little bit more aggressive in
dealing with upwind States pollution
going downwind but it's still not
perfect
so not to put you on the spot you said
the department really wasn't taking a
position one way or the other but you
said there's this is a good thing
so
oftentimes we as you know look to the
Departments to give us some real strong
guidance whether this is like a make or
break bill or not necessary so
would you rather see this pass or wait
and bring it up at a later date I I
would say that this is an important
issue that's not going away
I wouldn't think that it's a bad idea
for the Department to look at this
um we may not come back with all the
answers in two years I mean two years is
a relatively short period of time to
look at something that I think is very
complicated
um so I'm just going to leave it at that
represent grassy
yeah I I think that there was one thing
that you said that what I felt was very
important and that when you go to
hearings people are talking about this
people are asking you questions about
this you know what are the cumulative
impacts on a project and you know what's
happening next door to this project and
what what happened in the response of
the department gives them is that we
don't look at that
and I think that right there says that
we need to do something that we should
be looking at it and again I go back to
the the background that I have in
engineering with with drainage you can't
look at a project in a vacuum we need to
be looking at this accumulating and and
and I think that you know I I think it's
good you said that this is something you
really should be looking at even though
you're not officially taking a position
because I mean when the citizens are
asking these questions and the
department says we don't look at that
that's not acceptable
and but I understand you don't have the
regulations in place
you look at every project pretty much in
a vacuum and that's not the way we
should be doing it regardless and this
is small money to pay to get our rules
reviewed so that when people ask are you
looking at that you can say yes we've
considered that and the project is good
or the project is bad one or the other
or we need to make improvements I mean
we we've got to get ahead of this curve
because it's catching up to us and I
hate to see it that you know that that
we we tell people that we don't look at
that and then we have another single
bands on our hands we have problems that
we are going to spend millions and
billions of dollars correcting if we
don't anticipate them
I have a question for representative
grassy I'm going to call your expertise
now I know that at some point the
legislature passed legislation giving
towns planning boards uh the authority
to look at Regional impacts like if
there's a development next door they can
participate or to your point say if you
have a shopping center and there's not a
need for a traffic light and then
another one goes across the street now
there's a need for a traffic light
because they're looking at impacts do
you see this as like something similar
to at least
I don't know nothing yeah I do I think
that though that when we we look at a
lot of these projects whether it be
traffic impacts or it be drainage
impacts or it'd be air quality impacts a
lot of times we depend on Des to assist
us they do the reviews and if Des says
this Project's okay then the planning
boards sort of got their hands tied I
mean I've as a planner if Des came back
and said this project is is fine
I can't recommend to my board to deny a
project in in good conscience my board
may not be happy with it because they're
saying well we've got all these kind of
projects you know problems with traffic
and I say well you know dot says there's
no you know we're not gonna it doesn't
meet the the standards you have to do
something and they you know when we take
a look at traffic we tend to look at
cumulative impacts because you have
traffic studies done
um when you do drainage studies
unfortunately when you do drainage
studies you only look at one project and
vacuum when you do air quality studies
they're saying this now that yeah
occasionally we do look at things you
know in in a regional impact but most of
the time it's a project in a vacuum and
I think that this would give us more
regulations to be able to look at
particularly when it comes to a regional
a project or Regional impact which I
think is very important I actually have
a bill dealing with that with landfills
um and and that we should be looking at
them as a regional impact project and
Des should be looking at them as a
region impact project as well when they
review the project instead of project
and vacuum you know there may be things
that they'll put in their rules and
regulations that will say this will be a
trigger that if it meets this trigger
point then we will review it
um and and if it doesn't meet this
triggered point we won't review it and
you know that's something they're going
to have to look at and make those
determinations in their rules and
regulations that they make up and I
think that you know we do that in at the
local level uh where we have the ability
to do it we don't have scientists on
staff at the local levels we don't have
the engineers you know we have
Consultants Consultants that we work
with and sometimes they will bring
things to us but most of the time
um you know I
I think this is a good thing that we
that they should have this this ability
to do and I think again as I said it's a
small dollar that will help us
hopefully
uh
stop spending big dollars down the road
because if we don't do this it's going
to be far more costly
represent McGuire followed by evil
thank you Mr chairman can you answer
either of my previous two questions one
was
uh about the the amount of Regulation so
let's say some chemical would at a
certain parts per million would cause
one more case of cancer per year in New
Hampshire
do we allow
any project to have that amount right or
do we say well you can't have more than
a thousandth of that amount or a
hundredth of that amount or something
like that I mean where where do we draw
the line on in general so in in general
if um and I'll use air again as an
example
um
if somebody was subject to a modeling
analysis
they would be allowed to go right up to
the standard as an individual source
right but that's not my question my
question is how do you set the standard
well for the ear toxics is is we
we have a very prescribed method in the
statute and then the rules is how we set
the health-based standards we start with
EPA I'm sorry acgih American Conference
of gen industrial hygienists they have
what they call worker worker safety
values
we take those worker safety values which
are basically designed you're exposed
five days a week eight hours a day we
convert that to a your com your exposed
uh 24 hours a day 365 days a year over a
lifetime
so
it's a very prescribed methodology it's
how we set the standard
yeah but I didn't quite get from that
if you're exposed to that amount like
how many extra cases of cancer or deaths
or something well in theory if you are
subject to that amount there should be
no long-term health impact to you as an
individual unless the value is based on
an EPA cancer risk factor
then that EPA Factor does have some
value of like I want to assume it's a
one in a million or something along
those lines
yeah so it's very low I guess all right
it's very low unless it's you yeah yeah
um let me um let me ask the the other
question which was can you give us of
any specific example of of
this happening in New Hampshire right
one one exists a new one came in all of
a sudden we have a problem I I I can't
identify a specific case again but I
don't know what I don't know
hmm
any further questions uh representative
evil
sorry I did see because so much for
hiding back there
um
to remind the
can help us is it not true that this
bill started in the Senate as a bill
that would have required the department
to adopt regulations regarding Advanced
recycling
that is what the bill originally started
out as
well and and
um is it true that during the discussion
it sounds like a prosecutor isn't it
true that I know it's that lawyer in me
um
um that during the discussion it was
decided at the committee level and then
within the Senate that rather than just
singling out one industry it would be
better to look more closely at this sort
of analysis is more beneficial across
the board that's my recollection
and
answered perfect
so I I guess I would just observe that
in a state where we are dealing with the
unbelievably deleterious effects of
saint-gobain which is now closed we're
talking about new landfills I mean there
are so many hot button large potentially
or polluting projects that so much of
the populace is concerned with and this
was supported so strongly at the policy
level
I really do feel that two hundred
thousand dollars is small money to try
to do this analysis and I wouldn't want
to be the one to say that we didn't do
it so I still do support going forward
with the bill
representative Weiler
if I were in the Des I would tend to be
cautionary
and want everything
minimized
and an example of this is
I spoke with a person that set this 12
parts per trillion on pfas totally
unreasonable
a decade ago you couldn't measure things
to parts per trillion now suddenly you
can and we find things oh 12 parts per
trillion I said Give me the
give me the data give me the oh it's in
the it's in the letter it's in the
literature
you wouldn't give me any examples of why
he went to 12 parts per trillion and I
couldn't find any and until this money
in this budget went to look in Merrimack
at pfas
we have no human studies to make the
ridiculous claims of 12 parts per
trillion I I oppose it I think it's
stupid we can have 20 parts per million
of arsenic it's a deadly poison
pfas are so prevalent they're everywhere
in the in the air in the in the ground
so that we probably all of us have more
than 12 parts per trillion already in
our bodies if we use Scotch Guard on our
clothing or on our rugs or on our drapes
or exposed
so the the parts we've all absorbed and
once it's in your bloodstream it stays
there likely
we don't know what how it gets rid of
because it's it's such a stable compound
so dealing with this person in Des I
find it totally unreasonable and I don't
want to have and and the thing that that
this is going to cost if you have a
water system and suddenly it shows up
more than 12 per trillion you'll spend
millions of dollars trying to reduce
that pfas to 12 parts per trillion which
is virtually immeasurable in most
situations so I understand if I were in
your situation I would be cautious
and I would use my abilities from my
background to say yes this could be
dangerous
but
it's a little over cautious I think to
try to say oh we've got to look at all
these other factors which are very hard
to to put all together and and you know
for that reason I think that this leads
us down a dangerous path that would be
very expensive and it would be very
restrictive this pfas are going to be
very expensive if we try to
do that to every water supply system in
this state and it's going to be money
wasted I think when we suddenly discover
from maybe the long-term effects
in the study in Merrimack which I was in
favor of spending a couple of million
dollars on and we finally look at human
things and we have some data it's not
going to be 12 parts per trillion that
is ridiculous and so
I I understand Des likes to be cautious
and I'm happy that you are because
that's that's your that's your goal but
we have to look at it from the financial
standpoint is it worth it it's like
human cause global warming we will
destroy our economy because we might
have had this little bit effect on
global warming which
it's the sun there's not much we can do
about that so I'm opposed thank you
I don't think there was a question in
there but I I do just want to make one
comment that I will
very strongly state that the Des staff
are highly dedicated highly
professionally highly qualified
individuals
in a mantra from the top on down as we
follow the science that's all I'm going
to say
thank you and thank you for your
comments and testimony seeing no further
questions
thanks again
all right
so representative Sweeney would you like
to make a motion or comments I'm gonna
there is a motion
representative well I kind of did it yes
all right I would like to make a comment
then okay sure I didn't it wasn't
seconded though just a few months ago we
passed a great bipartisan budget that
spent a lot more money than I think some
people in this room were comfortable
with I know if I had my one say I would
have passed a budget that spent less but
it was a good compromise between the two
parties and we greatly expanded
government increased spending and gave
our state employees a great raise that
would almost design to help retain
employees and attract new employees so
that we could fill some of the vacancies
that we heard about earlier today and
other vacancies that exist throughout
state government
I don't I'm not going to jump into the
the policy of the bill I can register
that I don't support it but we're not
here for a policy committee we're here
for the finance committee and 247
thousand dollars adding in addition to
the budget we passed for a salaried
position that I think we can assume will
stay with us for the long term into the
next future budget Cycles uh to to study
this
policy that was not a direct request
from the department and it didn't make
its way into the budget is why I would
be opposing the ought to pass today and
if if that were to fail I would happy be
happy to make another motion on this
bill I don't
I think in the future there were a lot
of great arguments that representative
grassy and representative evil made
today that I hadn't heard on this
subject prior to and I think in a future
budget discussion and debate they would
have a lot of Merit there for inclusion
in the the overall Department budget but
at this moment today I'm not able to
support an expansion of another position
uh on top of what we've already did in
the budget
thank you representative Sweeney there
was a motion made I apologize I decided
to ask for a second but I will second
the motion just so we can continue the
discussion on the motion of ought to
pass
seeing no more discussion
when the cleric is ready please call the
roll on the motion of ought to pass
um representative McGuire no
representative Griffin
no
yes
okay the motion fails uh five to three
is there an alternative motion
representative Sweeney I believe is
moving itl yes and it's seconded by
representative kimberles
he said yes
uh representative McGuire yes
yes
no
not being quite 11 o'clock we have about
five minutes
so we'll reconvene
at 11 for uh house bill 436.
I can't
all right representative Weiler
so we'll now be 11 o'clock we'll move to
a house bill 436 and as was mentioned
earlier the chair of the retirement
commission representative Carol McGuire
has asked that we hold on to this should
the commission come out with some kind
of recommendations which feels like a
reasonable request
and any problem with that representative
Griffin
[Music]
all right and second by representative
Sweeney
all right and when the clerk is ready
please call the roll
yes
okay unanimous that will
continue to retain it
all right and uh that concludes our
business and really good to see you all
again and uh
we'll see you in November perhaps
all right again thanks
yeah so we'll probably for 436 needed
something before that yeah yeah before
Carol I believe she'll have her work
done by the November 1st right or
something
all right well that's a whole month
right
now
my arm was twisted by this gentleman
here
they I guess they don't have enough
input
gel powder Summits Aries
and while you mentioned yellow car there
was another role that representative
hatch did so well he was chair of gel
car for a number of years so
he'll be missed there
not an easy at all
right well thanks
they meet twice a month and Carol reads
something that's like this I mean it's
incredible that she actually does but
that's saying something
I don't get
all right well sometimes as you know I'm
the only one
well some of us do skim though
it depends on the agency
[Laughter]
all right well thanks again we'll see
you in the near future